have you heard of mouth taping and nose
breathing and mouthpiece i have i
haven't read the book breathe but isn't
that kind of sort of what they talk
about and so if you're breathing through
your mouth when you're sleeping what can
happen is because you're you're through
the neurology of sleep your central
nervous system innervates your muscles
and your tongue is a major muscle and so
when you're in rem sleep in particular
your tongue can become temporarily
paralyzed it sounds a little weird but
if you're breathing through your mouth
and you're laying back you can envision
if your tongue is not getting any sort
of tonic nervous system input it can
collapse your airway and this is very
common way more common than people
realize like sleep disorder breathing is
a spectrum people you have normal you
know nasal breathing then on the other
end of the spectrum you have sleep apnea
most of us are kind of in the middle
where we have these periodic apnic
events
and it's called sleep disorder breathing
so
one of one clue of people who have this
is they wake up in the middle of night
to go pee because when you're having
this sort of temporarily parallel you
know choking yourself on your own tongue
which is crazy a lot of people do this
um it affects vasopressin and the
retention of water and so it can cause
you to go pee so that's a sim i'm not
saying get your mouse free
the specific tape is called three the
company 3m the 3m micropore tape i
encourage people to just experiment with
this it can be a game changer for sleep
and you mentioned the cortisol awakening
response so what you what i encourage my
clients to do is before putting on
before bed you can maybe take it out in
the evening put some tape on when you're
reading a book or doing something else
and get comfortable breathing through
your nose and so on um and yeah that's
how we should be breathing when we're
sleeping is through our nose and the
tape can just help facilitate that i'm
friends with um gab gabby um and laird
uh claire hamilton gaby reese and she
would sometimes uh have us because she
would lead some workouts and
um she would say okay go on the rower
row 5000 but breathe out of your nose
only and i was like oh man it's crazy
with how much different it is to breathe
just through your nose especially when
you're doing activity but that's a great
tip for at night
what are some things that people can do
because i mean i wonder about this for
myself how do we know if we're
in adrenal fatigue how do we know if
we're uh our cortisol is because i was
here too there's also the other side of
it where your cortisol is through the
roof and so what are what are your
recommended tests to see if peop if
because if somebody's suspicious
of
where they're at um biologically because
we also all think oh we're fine but even
a heated conversation raises your blood
sugar so what do you recommend for
people
yeah well the test that you recommended
the dutch test i i do quite like that
because it does look at the sort of the
the rhythmicity of your hormones and the
metabolites throughout the day so you'll
see the cortisol awakening response the
time then you also can look at dhea and
that's something we can take a deeper
dive into but
um but so that's like an objective way
to sort of quantify hey how are my
adrenal glands doing if people just want
to ask themselves you know sort of
subjectively you know the big things are
how do you feel when you wake up in the
morning i.e are you ready to go hit the
day are you excited do you have energy
or are you like oh my gosh i can barely
get out of bed i'm exhausted i'm tanked
um i'm lethargic i'm like have no energy
to work out i get dizzy when i stand up
very sensitive to sunlight that's
another thing as well
and then also if your rhythm's all sort
of messed up then some people can be
sort of tired but wired when they should
be ready to go to bed so some people
their adrenals start to really kick in
because of circadian clock disruption
later in the day and so your cortisol
should be at its lowest point around
bedtime
um but for some people it's starting to
get high and that's why they're like
dude i'm like i have so much energy now
that so i'm gonna binge watch netflix
and this and then fall asleep at four in
the morning and it just creates this
really not so good cycle so
you know there's some sort of
controversy in in the whole health
community really what is adrenal fatigue
is it just circadian rhythm disruption
because again
you should have a strong cortisol
awakening response but so many people
now are exposed to artificial light we
have leds in in compact fluorescence we
have televisions we have screens and so
that could that's enough light to pivot
the entire circadian clock system to
trigger your adrenals to start making
cortisol when it really should not be so
there's that element of it but then
there's also the life load aspect the
psychological stressors and all that so
what do we do about it i'm a big fan of
dhea so this is a hormone that a lot of
people aren't really familiar with but
it's a mother hormone that feeds into
estrogen and testosterone and the
adrenal glands we've all heard of
andropause and we see all these hrt
clinics everywhere hormone replacement
therapy clinics are it's on the radio
and so we've heard of menopause which is
where women stop making you know
reproductive hormones and so forth but
we have adrenopods your adrenals
naturally in some people can go through
a state of sort of uh can take a little
hiatus
and so that one of the hormones that
really can decline as you age is called
dhea
and you can test for this again the
dutch test looks at it but if you just
get blood work from your primary care
doctor or a functional medicine doctor
dha sulfate is what you'd look for
i'm seeing this people that i work with
in their 20s it's very low
and so when dhea is low then their
testosterone is going to be low then
their estrogens are going to be low and
this can be very problematic so um
yeah i i honestly i think it's a
combination the circadian rhythm
disruptions the psychological stressors
and all that but in your case
because and i don't know how recent the
dutch test was and i would want to look
at your other hormones but i might
suggest considering taking like five
milligrams or maybe 10 milligrams of
dhea
around 8 pm at night do you take dha i
do yeah yeah i took 5 milligrams for a
while i take 10 milligrams right now
okay and i take it in the morning
well so here's the thing
and maybe i'm guilty of recommending i
used to recommend dha in the morning but
it can be used especially for people
like yourself who the pattern is a
little off it might help push because
dha can sort of antagonize cortisol a
little bit okay and again there's not
huge studies showing this but it's just
a small handful of studies so it makes
sense to try it one of those though and
it makes a difference
yeah so if you can and if that cortisol
is maybe waking you up or causing light
sleep that could be helpful so try to
take that 10 milligrams like with your
evening supplements maybe an hour before
bed oh that's a good idea
yeah i sleep um
i don't know if you've come across
anybody like this but i wake up awake
every day like i never wake up tired i
wake up i'm super alert ready to go i
don't even need coffee i just love it um
and i'm tired at night and i'm hungry in
the morning and i'm not hungry at night
um
but i don't i also don't need a lot of
sleep like i have had patches of my life
where i'm like
okay i know like five hours is not
really enough but that's like all i'm
sleeping right now and i'm fine i feel
fine but i know from a health
perspective
that this is detrimental um so
is there any
person in the world that can survive on
six i mean i get right now because i'm i
try and get as much sleep as possible i
mean i rarely get eight but seven is
kind of the number for me
um six and a half is
fine seven and a half's great
is there anyone that can get away with
low sleep and or is sleep always
necessary for the circadian rhythm and
for your hormones to do what it needs to
do through the night and honestly i
think it depends on who you ask i would
say
if
think about have an honest evaluation of
your energy and how you feel in the
morning and if you're waking up without
an alarm ready to go
five or seven hours right like i think
that's probably sufficient for you but
if you were like oh yeah i need a nap at
three o'clock and i'm just exhausted
then probably not getting enough sleep
but matthew walker um will tell you that
and he's got a phd he's really into the
brain and preventing alzheimer's and
things like that
that um
not getting less than seven hours is
insufficient for clearing up some of the
metabolic debris in your brain
that naturally builds up throughout the
day and so you have this whole sort of
cleansing sort of like a dishwasher
process going on in your glio lymphatic
system of the brain so if for short
changing sleep then over time we can
build up metabolites that might
predispose us to early onset
neurodegenerative disorders so just be
mindful of that now that doesn't mean
that if you have one night of just five
hours that you're doomed it just means
hey maybe take a nap try to you can bank
your sleep as well so if you know that
you're going to be traveling
hanging out with friends you haven't
seen in two years and you're like we're
going to be parting it up it's like okay
well maybe take an extra nap that day or
try to aim to get more sleep uh ahead of
time so you can sleep bank yeah that's
helpful you know that made me think of
um so last year i ran the boston
marathon and so i had a garmin for
really just like to know how far i was
going i wasn't using it for too much
more but um but hrv was something that i
was told to track and um just because
it's a it's like a my the functional
doctor at the time said it's a sort of a
foolproof way to know how your body's
doing because you can't cheat the heart
rate
and i found that very interesting and
since so many people wear wearables um
as soon as the marathon was over with i
took that thing off like i don't i i
i learned enough to know that when i
drink a little
i get like half the recovery and i know
that um
i know that if i don't then i generally
recover to sort of like i don't know 80
90 100 sometimes
so i just kind of felt like i was doing
fine but um but i also in recent time
have seen how people can um
you know with heart rate variability
track
um also illnesses coming on like it'll
pick it up before you even feel it and
so
like i don't know makeup do you wear a
wearable
i do yeah i have a garmin i wear the
watch and then i also wear the aura ring
at night mm-hmm yeah
a little bit yeah it doesn't totally
jive you know i just like the garmin
watch i like to go out hiking in the
back country so i i do like like it's
it's yeah barometric pressure there's
all these other features to it and then
the steps are kind of nice but the the
hr i don't wear this when i'm sleeping
um
the the aura ring how they built it is
it's a lower emf device so that yeah
when you're sleeping and all this you
don't have all these non-native
frequencies right in your you know
temple and all that um so yeah the aura
ring is good because that will give you
an average and you're right like so many
people will tell you gosh my hiv tanked
in fact when i had kovitz in december of
2020 i knew something was off i didn't
think it was coveted at the time because
it was kind of quite mild but my hrv
totally tanked and my heart rate started
to increase so that was a sign that hey
something's sort of wrong here then i
started to call friends that i was with
and turns out they all had it right so
anyway um i think it's a great thing to
re for people to be aware of for sure
[Music]
you